이야
Zum lacking
Findest Du es?
Weißt Du was Ich finde?
Nice!
Aijajaa
So, gucken wir mal ob Twitch schon gecheckt hat, dass der Stream on ist, sieht nicht so
aus.
Twitch ist da teilweise nicht so geschwind.
Hab das Gefühl, dass Twitch manchmal, ah jetzt ist er am Start, man sieht das immer,
wenn auf einmal im Chat gleichzeitig was gepostet wird, dann weißt du, jetzt hat es Twitch gecheckt,
weil die Leute brauchen ungefähr gleich lang.
So, auf zu, es ist manchmal merkwürdig, manchmal braucht das 2 Sekunden, manchmal
braucht das 3 Minuten oder so, komisch, naja.
Discord hat es gecheckt, ja siehst du, aber Discord checkt es erst, wenn es Twitch gecheckt
hat.
Das dauert manchmal ein bisschen, also man sieht es ja, ich bin jetzt 2 Minuten on und
jetzt hat Twitch 2 Minuten gebraucht, quasi bis der Discord das gecheckt hat.
Ich hatte übrigens gestern Abend noch eine Idee, wir haben ja gestern 5 Stunden, warte
mal, ich mach mal kurz den Trezzy, der Sleeper, ich will mich gar nicht selbst angucken.
Übrigens, wisst ihr was richtig bescheuert ist, dass man jetzt hier teilweise auf den
Namen draufklicken muss, dass man Videos sieht und sowas, ja ja, guck hier jetzt, ach guck
mal, jetzt haben sie es wieder geschafft, dass Videos hier angezeigt werden, ok, also
wir haben ja gestern 5 und ein halbe Stunden ESP32 programmiert, denke mal die ein oder
andere waren vielleicht dabei.
SGDQ ist durch, ich habe ganz wenig geguckt diesmal nur, aber ich habe es ja schon gesagt,
dass mich das jetzt halt so extrem überkorrekt sind und der Chat gesperrt ist, das interessiert
mich das nicht mehr so.
Ich hatte nämlich hierzu gestern, was wir gestern gemacht haben, also eine richtig gute
Idee, gestern Abend und zwar, wir könnten für das Update was wir machen, wir könnten
noch so ein Minimal Web Interface bauen, dass man auch wie Normalsterbliche das Update
über den Browser hochladen kann und nicht irgendwie per Curl über die Kommandozeile
das machen muss.
Streams nicht selbst schauen, ne, das machen wir vielleicht schon Mittag, wie gesagt ich
wollte heute Mittag eh weiter machen mit dem T-Display, aber wir bauen glaube ich so Minimal
Web Interface.
So gut wie einfach, das Thumbnail für das Wort von gestern ist echt, warum, was habe
ich jetzt gar nicht gesehen.
Max, ruhig, ruhig.
Das ist leider nicht das Thumbnail, das Thumbnail ist das, aber das hier wäre das bessere Thumbnail
gewesen.
Ja, das kommen wir, da bauen wir am Mittag nämlich vielleicht ein Web Interface dazu,
dass man so ein Upload-Button hat, die richtige PP über das Web Interface, ja, ne, ja, das
ist das.
Wie gesagt, ich habe eh gesagt, ich lade dann zumindest den Code für den Updater auf GitHub
hoch und ich glaube die meisten benutzen sowas lieber über den Browser zum Firmware hochladen
als jetzt unbedingt über Curl mit dann einfach noch so einem MD5-Sum-Befehl für die Check-Sum
und sowas.
Schon mal Fall Guys gespielt, ne, das ist ein Game, was mich jetzt überhaupt nicht anspricht,
wo ich auch nicht gerne zugucke, es gibt Spiele, da gucke ich gerne zu, die ich nicht spiele,
zum Beispiel Valorant, da gucke ich ganz gerne ab und zu mal zu oder CS, spiele ich ja auch
nicht mehr, großartig, aber Fall Guys finde ich weder zum zugucken, noch irgendwie spricht
mich das großartig an.
Hey Leute, MonkaS, Monach, Monachs, warum, ich finde es eigentlich ganz gut zum zugucken,
zum Spielen, kein Schimmer.
Eins muss man denen aber echt mal lassen und hier machen wir guckt, Twitch, Games, äh,
Directory, nicht Games, äh, gut, das ist ja grad der übelste Hype, guck mal, der Kram
hat allen Ernstes mehr Zuschauer, wie, wie, wie Warzone und Fortnite, alter, null, ja,
aber ich vermute mal Fall Guys, also entweder, sie machen dies richtig big brain, dass die
irgendwelche Kooperationen mit allen anderen bekannten Games starten, was das dann in dem
Game irgendwie gibt, äh, oder aber in einem Monat interessiert das kein Mensch mehr, mal
gucken.
Also gibt es die zwei Möglichkeiten, denke ich, C4 Ducky Twitch Prime, dankeschön, excellent
Subscription, Massive Brain Sub, pure Streamer Loch, weiß ich nicht, äh, Streamer Sommer
Loch, ähm, genau, also man muss den ja schon mal sagen, guck mal hier, also dafür, dass
es ein neues Game ist, ohne dass da irgendwie sonderlich viel jetzt noch gemacht wird gerade,
also jetzt irgendwie an Promotion Geschichten und sonst was, außer die üblichen Sachen,
es reicht schon, dass das ein Game ist, von einem Hersteller, wo die Leute wissen, dass
es nicht wie in Battlefield oder Overwatch morgen vorbei mit Support, ja, also Overwatch
ist ja Support schon mehr oder weniger Sparflamme seit zwei Jahren, weiß ich auch nicht, was
mit Blizzard los ist und, äh, gut, Battlefield 5 hat es ja eh erledigt, ja, na, guck mal,
wo ist denn Overwatch eigentlich gerade, wo ist es denn, ja, hier, äh, Wahnsinn, immer
noch 13.000, wahrscheinlich weil es einen Streamer mit 5k gibt oder so, ja, weil ansonsten
Overwatch nix, wenn er nicht einer der großen Streamer so am Start ist, naja, ja, und es
sind auch fast, das stimmt, es sind fast nur noch Koreaner, aber selbst in Korea wird es
kaum noch gespielt, ich finde es, ich finde es witzig, seit die umgezogen sind, das muss
ich jetzt sagen, man kann angeblich mittlerweile Custom, man kann angeblich Custom, äh, Roms
mittlerweile, Custom Software mittlerweile auf 2DS machen und das finde ich äußerst
spannend, denn ich habe noch ein 2DS rumfliegen, moin TH, es ist jetzt in 10 Monate, ich dachte,
du hast gestern schon gesubbt, hast du entsubbt und wieder neu zu subben, nicht für 10 Monate,
huge subscription, erstmal kurz ein bisschen kleiner machen das ganze, ja, also da bin
ich echt mal gespannt drauf, was der hier erzählt, ansonsten, ich habe, ich habe paar
random Videos mal aufgemacht, die ganz, ganz interessant angehört haben, was wir uns heute
angucken können und was alle packen, weiß ich nicht, müssen wir mal gucken, äh, irgendein
Minimal PC Bild, auf irgendeinem komischen, das sah ganz merkwürdig aus, auf irgendeinem
komischen, what the fuck, ich mein, das ist ein komisches Geräusch, müssen wir mal gucken,
was da am Ende rauskommt, äh, Flappy Bird RTX On, keine Ahnung, ob das was taucht, irgendwie,
ich wusste gar nicht, dass Doktor Disrespect ein 315.000 Dollar PC hat, ich frag mich allen
ernstes, wie man auf ein 315.000 Dollar PC kommt, ich mein, ein 15.000 Dollar PC ist
schon ziemlich schwer, generell alles über ein 5.000 Dollar PC ist schon für den Desktop
Bereich schwer, also, du musst dann schon Sachen einbauen, die absolut unsinnig sind,
also sprich, also mit 5.000 Dollar, da kannst du dir sogar eine SLI 2080 Ti oder 3080 Ti,
wenn es dann rauskommt, einbauen, warum ist Max eigentlich von YouTube zu Twitch gewechselt,
ich bin doch gar nicht gewechselt, meinen Channel gibt es doch immer noch, ich habe noch nie
Livestreams auf YouTube gemacht, weil Livestreaming auf YouTube sackt, außer man ist Doktor Disrespect
dem E30 Milliarden Leute zu gucken, und außerdem mag ich YouTube als Streaming Plattform nicht,
und Doktor Disrespect ist ja auch nur da, weil er für Twitch gewandt hat, gibt es dazu
eigentlich irgendwas Neues, gibt es dazu irgendwelche Sachen, die, was ja wohl jetzt rausgekommen
ist, warum, weil, da hast du nix mal von gehört, außer dass Twitch absolut nichts sagt, dass
es irgendwie so Big Brain Leute wie den Slasher gibt, der sagt, ja ich weiß es, aber ich sag
es nicht, und dann hast du Doktor Disrespect, der sagt, der weiß es selber nicht, komisch,
sehr merkwürdig, sehr merkwürdig, bin mal gespannt, was da rauskommt, ich hoffe ja,
dass so Verhandlungen in den USA irgendwie public sind, und die sich jetzt irgendwie
noch verklagen, und dass man da irgendwie was rausbekommt, da bin ich mal gespannt,
was der dazu sagt, wir haben schon lange kein Fortschritt-Video mehr geguckt, ich meine,
nachdem wir jetzt ja Modern Warfare Remastered bekommen haben, Modern Warfare 2 Remastered,
mal gucken, wie es dagegen aussieht, irgendeinem kurz gesagt Video, mal gucken, ein neues
Electro-Boom-Video haben wir noch, was haben wir sonst noch hier, Battlefield Top Plays,
Homelab Tour, da kann ich ein bisschen über das Rack und Zeug von anderen Leuten lästern,
das ist immer gut, da muss ich mein eigenes Zeug nicht aufräumen, ob das was taugt, weiß
ich, mal schauen, übrigens wisst ihr, was ich letztens gesehen hab, das da, es kann
sein, dass, ich glaube jetzt lacht mich nicht aus der Chat, ich glaube das habe ich bei
Chip gesehen, ich weiß auch nicht, wie ich zu Chip gekommen bin, könnte ich gleich noch
bei der PC Welt als nächstes gucken oder so, es kann sein, dass diese Sache hier defaultmäßig
eingeschaltet, also bei mir war die Sache hier defaultmäßig eingeschaltet, und wenn
man Pech hat, steht das so, und in dieser Kombination, wenn das in dieser Kombination
steht, dann schickt man selbst an andere Leute im Internet Updates, um die mal gute Quelle
zu Chip, aber in dem Fall hatten sie recht, dann schickt man an andere Leute im Internet
Updates, um die Microsoft Server zu entlasten, das will man natürlich nicht, das will man
nicht, ich soll die mal schön selbst ausliefern, haben wir hier sonst noch so Top 10 Programmierideen
für eine Art, das ist mir heute zu anstrengend, die Frage ist einfach beantwortet, das Video
müssen wir uns eigentlich gar nicht angucken, warum Netflix jetzt auch schlechte Shows
macht, ganz einfach, weil es Geld bringt, Netflix setzt jetzt neuerdings vermehrt auf
Reality TV, naja, ich sag mal Angler Camp, oder Angel Camp, wie auch immer das hieß,
weil es Geld bringt, das ist die offensichtlichste Antwort, wir gucken uns jetzt aber mal an,
wie man Homebrew, also so Custom Software auf dem 2DS installieren kann, da bin ich
echt mal gespannt drauf, weil ich hab noch ein 2DS rumfliegen irgendwo, in irgendeiner
Ecke, legt der 2DS rum, den hab ich mir damals gekauft, hab ich da nicht sogar ein Video
zu gemacht, war das ein 2DS oder ein 3DS, ah 3DS, ah fuck, dann hab ich, oh nein, da
kann ich das ja gar nicht installieren, ich hab mir den damals nämlich aus Australien
bestellt, weil lustigerweise Nintendo 2014 auch noch irgendwelche Region-Log-Geschiss
drin hat, was totaler Schwachsinn war, weil, ne, also, warum macht man 2014, naja, aber
es ist Nintendo, die sind bei allem 10 Jahre später und dann kriegen sie es trotzdem nicht
gescheit hin, das ist gar kein 2DS, vielleicht, wenn wir Glück haben, geht das vielleicht
auch mit dem 3DS, wahrscheinlich nicht, ja, ja, fuck, das geht ja gar nicht, aber Hunt
League, Hunt Reveal, oh ne, dann geht das ja gar nicht, naja, zumindest Big Brain, ich
hab mir das damals ganz neu, weil ich irgendwas spielen wollte, weil ich glaube, was, Spirit
Tracks, irgendwas wollte ich unbedingt spielen und da hab ich mir den aus Australien damals
bestellt und direkt aus Australien importiert, war wahrscheinlich mir viel zu viel Geld und
dann hatte ich den da, hab den eingerichtet, WLAN angemacht, sieht man ja auch, ja, WLAN
eingerichtet und danach hab ich ihn nie wieder angehabt, ich hab den, ich hab den importiert
aus Australien, weil ich unbedingt irgendwas spielen wollte und nach dem ersten Eindruck-Video
hab ich ihn nie wieder eingeschaltet, also richtig Low Brain eigentlich, ich hab das
dann auch nie gespielt, was ich spielen wollte, ach ne, A Link Between Worlds war das, was
ich spielen wollte, genau, das hab ich noch original verpackt hier liegen, obbei ne, stimmt
gar nicht, das hab ich gar nicht mehr original verpackt hier liegen, das hab ich inklusive
nem Bowser Amiibo, hab ich das mal in nem Speedrun Event als Preis gedonatet, hab ich
gar nicht mehr, so, also, gucken wir mal, aber trotzdem, vielleicht gehts ja auch für
3DS XL, Homebrew sollte auch gehen, ja, ich glaub, der ist sogar neuer als der, den ich
da gezeigt hab, ne, die haben doch danach noch nen 2DS rausgebracht, weil die Leute irgendwie
von 3D so abgeschreckt waren, merkwürdig ist, weil man konnte 3D beim 3DS einfach ausschalten,
ja.
Nintendo double down on the 3DS line and randomly announced a new handheld known as the new Nintendo 2DS XL
Priced at $149.99 US the 2DS XL takes the new 3DS XL and removes some features
But with the added performance boost of the new XL line meant that the 2DS XL is a significant boost in performance over the earliest
slate model the Nintendo 2DS
3DS
Ja gut das wird wahrscheinlich mehr oder weniger der 3DS sein den ich auch habe ohne 3D
von der Hardware
The Nintendo 3DS lifespan has been going strong for over 9 years
Selling over 75 million units
Aber jetzt ist vorbei also jetzt ist vorbei mit dem DS also ich habe jetzt bei den letzten Nintendo Sachen
Ich muss ehrlich sagen ich hab nur Zusammenfassungen geguckt, ich hab die letzten Nintendo gab's ja auch nicht so viele Directs und Sachen mehr
Aber da wurde nichts mehr zum 3DS gezeigt oder oder fällt von euch jemand irgendwie ein ob Nintendo was noch zum 3DS gezeigt hat also meines
Ja ach es kam da eigentlich nichts mehr es kam nur noch Switch zeugs
2DS XL
Haha $9.90 nicht in deutschland
Gebetet
Jetzt ist vielleicht woanders günstiger
Youtube Money Max ist auch was ach nee geht gar nicht an mich
Ich bin ja ultra werbefreundlich mit dem was ich mache genau
Das ist so also ich glaube die einzigen die aktuell bei mir irgendwie werbung machen könnten wäre so ein china PCB hersteller
Da müsste ich dann einmal im stream sagen und wenn ihr super billige eigene boards machen wollt dann geht zu PCB way oder irgendwas
Also wenn mich wenn mich wenn mich AliExpress oder Banggood immer der Name von dem Shop der macht mich jedes mal fertig wenn ich das hier aber wenn mich AliExpress und Banggood sponsoren würden ey das easy easy life
Ja mach hinne zeig her
Ich bin ja super werbefreundlich mit dem was ach nee geht gar nicht an mich
Jetzt kriegen wir wieder was beigebracht chat
Oi ach nee
Fuck you
Silly champ
Was gucken wir uns heute an?
Coggers
Ok Champ
Was Video lauter? Ist das zu leise?
Ok ok
Jetzt aber oder?
Das verwende ich nicht, ich spam nur easy clap, easy clap ist die bessere Variante
Also ich hab kein easy clap emote, ich hab nur ein clap emote und ich hab ein easy emote
Ich brauch noch nen easy clap, gibts noch nen easy clap gif?
Ja aber mit, mit
Ich brauch nen easy clap gif mit transparent
Gibt kein easy clap transparent? Was ist das denn?
Warum gibt es kein easy clap transparent Leute?
Ich brauch das, warum das ist ja, kann doch nicht sein dass es das nicht gibt
Excusi als erstes Ergebnis
Warum gibt es easy clap nicht transparent? Dann kann ich leider nicht hinzufügen
Weil das sieht doof aus, guck mal wenn ich das hier jetzt nehme
Dann sieht das so aus wie hypers
Das ist auch doof, das muss ich auch mal löschen
Das lösche ich nur nicht, weil sich dann meine emotes reordern
Und transparent sieht doof aus
Easy clap gif transparent, gibt es nicht?
Ja, müssen wir jetzt weiter gucken
Peace bet man
Das ist übrigens, das ist übrigens jetzt
Das ist übrigens auch ein Sponsorship wo ich, wo ich komplett mitmachen würde
Ich würde mich sofort von irgendeinem Snack-Anbieter sponsoren lassen
Sofort
Wenn da irgendeiner kommt und sagt Max, Futter im Stream, unser Zeug
Und erzählen den Leuten wie geil das schmeckt, würde ich sofort machen
Unter der Voraussetzung, es ist wirklich, es schmeckt auch gut
Weil ich hab keinen Bock, also es gibt ja kaum was schlimmeres als ekliges Essen was du essen musst
Hotpockets
Den Ausschnitt, da hab ich sogar geguckt
Da hat Dan erzählt wie es so ist, so der Weg als zu einem erfolgreichen großen Streamer
Wo er halt gesagt hat, okay da macht er halt den ganzen Tag Stream und jetzt hat er sich halt ein Büro geholt
Dass er überhaupt mal noch rausgeht und ein paar Leute sieht
Und er kennt halt nicht viele Leute
Kommt drauf an wie sozial man ist, ich hab kein Problem damit wenn ich wenig mit Leuten zu tun hab
Weil ich mag Leute allgemein nicht
Zettke ist ein übelst dummes Emote
Die Animationen sind aber schon nice die er macht
Weirdchamp
Q-Y-X-Logo
Ja
Pfeffer
Outro
Wenn du nicht in die Party kommen kannst, wenn du nicht in die tolle Kinderstelle kommen kannst, kannst du mit mir sitzen. Du kannst in meine Party kommen. Du kannst in meine Heimat kommen. Ich werde deine Reaktion sein.
Warum drehen manche Leute so übelst ab?
Ich mein, klar, da ist es wahrscheinlich nicht mehr ernst gemeint, aber...
Ich gucke am liebsten Streams, die ich theoretisch auch im Hintergrund laufen lassen kann. Und Leute, die einfach random anfangen zu schreien, das kriege ich im Anfall.
Ey, meinen E-Mote, was schaffst du?
Verwendet kaum noch einer.
Ja, verwendet kaum noch einer.
Also, ich benutze das immer, also ich benutze das und das so ungefähr synonym. Also sprich, wenn irgendwas einfach hängen geblieben ist.
Low brain, low brain. Gibt es heute auch ein Battlefield-Video, ja? Wahrscheinlich sogar als nächstes.
Allerdings muss man gucken, ob wir das nicht schon können.
Beste, beste.
Kogals beste.
Ja, ja.
Okay, Klasse, danke für die Aufmerksamkeit heute. Als Rezendat werden wir alle mit einem Film behandelt, Klasse.
Es heißt, die Geschichte der Youtube- und Twitch-Wars oder so. Das sollte ein guter Schaum sein.
Okay, Klasse, danke für die Aufmerksamkeit heute. Als Rezendat werden wir alle mit einem Film behandelt, Klasse. Es heißt, die Geschichte der Youtube- und Twitch-Wars oder so. Das sollte ein guter Schaum sein. Allerdings, Klasse, ich hoffe, ihr habt einen guten restlichen Tag und ich sehe euch im nächsten Klasse.
Danke schön für 14 Monate Subscription. Huge.
Übrigens, wer gestern nicht dabei war, im Stream, wir haben gestern eines der wichtigsten Sachen schlechthin programmiert. Wir haben es geschafft, AJAJA auf einem Display anzuzeigen.
Auf dem ESP32-Microcontroller-Display. Ganz, es ist eines der wichtigsten Projekte aller Zeiten gewesen.
So, was gucken wir als nächstes? Battlefield. Wir gucken eine Runde Battlefield. Das ist wirklich nicht verkehrt. Wir gucken echt eine Runde Battlefield.
Lining them up on Battlefield-Top-Plays. Wir müssen mal gucken, ob wir das nicht schon kennen. Das ist ein bisschen älter, aber ich glaube, wir haben es noch nicht geguckt. Falls wir das schon kennen, müsst ihr was sagen. Aber meistens merke ich das ja selber.
Ja, deswegen stellt man sich auch nicht an diese mobilen Geschütze dran, weil man ist sofort tot normalerweise. Was ist das? Ist das gestellt? Was ist mit denen los? Bescheuert kann man doch nicht sein, sich da an die Geschütze zu stellen.
Was ist mit dem Gegner los? Ist das Singleplayer-Kampagne? Ist das... Alter Movement-Götter hier wieder am Start.
Hello and welcome to the Battlefield. Deswegen sieht man in allen Spielen, gute Spieler bewegen sich ständig.
Na ja, okay, das stimmt nicht ganz. Guckt euch CS an. Wobei selbst in CS ist es nicht so, dass irgendwie Leute einfach mal grundlos zwei Minuten in die gleiche Richtung gucken. Aber in der Regel ist es so, gute Spieler bewegen sich ständig und machen ständig irgendwas.
In Overwatch ist man zum Beispiel die ganze Zeit sinnlos am AD-AD-Spam, weil das Movement im Spiel bescheuert ist.
On Langkang Dam with the JNG-90.
Ja, bei CS ist das Movement nicht bescheuert. In Overwatch ist es so, dass es keine Beschleunigung gibt. Also in Overwatch bist du Movement-mäßig von 0 auf 100, was ja prinzipiell okay ist für dich selbst vom Spielgefühl her, aber auch für andere Spieler.
Und wenn du in Overwatch Strafe links, rechts, links, rechts spammst, zappelst du halt wild hin und her, weil das Spiel voll Speed nach links, voll Speed nach rechts animiert. Voll bescheuert.
Deswegen siehst du Spieler, die quasi irgendwie einfach nur überleben wollen und wenn sie normalen Moven keine Chance haben, einfach nur ein bisschen mit...
So, und dann wirst du übelst schlecht getroffen. Vor allem wenn du Minidiva bist und sowas hier machst. Ey, dich trifft keine Sau.
Richtig, richtig hängen geblieben. Ist das Max FPS, lebt der immer noch? Nee, nee, der lebt nicht.
Hab ich schon... Nee, den gibt's nicht mehr. Wobei ich heute ein neues Video machen wollte. Hab ich gestern geteasert. Aber wenn wir heute Mittag weiter Programmier-Stream machen, da kann ich heute kein neues Video machen.
Weil irgendwann muss ich das machen.
Neues Video Postchamp. Das ist seit ein paar Monaten schon gepostchamp. Einfach im Stream aufnehmen. Nee.
Ja und ich muss ja immer noch Gameplay oder irgendwas zusammenschnibbeln und so. Das kann ich nicht im Stream machen.
Oh, nice. Ich mein, es ist halt übels Glück, dass die da sich hier durch Kolleterellen lassen.
Besser Spot. Wobei ein noch besserer Spot ist. Wobei, nee, das ist der gute Spot. Vergiss, das ist der gute Spot. Das ist der gute Spot.
Eins weiter vorne ist auch noch ein guter Spot. Oh, wie sie da stehen, dass sie mich hinkriegen.
Aber Battlefield 3, das würde ich sagen, weniger hat geklitscht. Ich finde, man trifft in Battlefield 3 die Leute, die da rausgucken, ganz gut.
Vor allem macht es auch den Kopf übels Damage, wenn du triffst. Generell halt Deckungsmovement ist in Battlefield 3 huge.
Die lassen sich ja so heftigst wegsprayen.
Das ist die Munition auch noch. Ich hätte jetzt ehrlich gesagt, hätte ich irgendein Kit aufgehoben, was da rumliegt.
Okay, jetzt hier liegt gerade nichts rum, aber da vorne etwas rumgelegt. Aber da musst du doch erst mal dran denken.
Alter, die lassen sich so krass wegsprayen, die Gegner. Wahnsinn.
Unrun Dead, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das nächste Battlefield wieder in der jetzigen Zeit spielt.
Gehe ich sogar mal von aus. Zumindest irgendwas in dem Dreh jetzt.
Übrigens, MonkaS, wisst ihr, in welchem Jahr Battlefield 4 spielt?
Wisst ihr, in welchem Jahr Battlefield 4 spielt?
Ja, Cap'n Peng an Recht 2020.
Battlefield 4 spielt 2020. Allerdings haben sie es ziemlich schlecht prediktet.
Wir haben zwar gerade Probleme, aber andere Probleme als in Battlefield 4.
Wobei ich ganz ehrlich sagen muss, mir ist Corona lieber als 3. Weltkrieg mit China und USA.
3. Weltkrieg mit China und USA. Ist mir Corona lieber.
Oh, da lassen sie sich wieder schön mit der LMG wegsprayen.
Habt ihr die hässliche Reflektion gesehen gerade?
Gut, ne, ist ja nicht so, als wäre das jetzt relevant, aber ist mir nur gerade aufgefallen.
Manche Battlefield Sports sind halt teilweise echt wir.
Also gerade Battlefield 4 auf locker, ist das C-Flage?
Das sport man teilweise hinter den Gegnern. Manchmal, wenn man Pech hat oder Glück hat hier nachdem.
Metro, was sonst? Wir haben schon lange kein Metro mehr gesehen.
Man kann das hat größer machen, doch?
Ich mach mal kurz ein bisschen leiser.
Wenn die Metro-Boys hier weggesprayen. Alter, Leute dreht euch um.
Dreht euch um. Guckt halt mal.
Kein Bock.
Umdrehen ist overrated.
Ich würde mich gerne einen Moment mit diesem Video schenken. Sponsoren ist Instant Gaming.
Wie ihr wisst, haben sie ein bisschen witzig.
Er ist hinter dem Gegner-Team, das ist die perfekte Position.
Schließlich, obwohl er ein paar Schüsse verpasst.
... mit der M416, bevor man über einen anderen Weg in den Gegnern denkt.
Und da sind sie. Ein großer Spraydown mit der M416.
Und der zweite Clip ist ein Clip aus dem Knuschar-Kanal.
Oh, die Sniper-Turm. Die Sniper-Turm.
Der weiß genau, wenn er hier oben stehen bleibt, wird der Clip nicht genommen.
Die Posi da oben, ey.
Wir haben einen Gegner-Sniper in der Region gesponsert.
Noch ein weiterer Clip, aber dieses Mal ein bisschen länger.
Von Russel & Jimmars, der M40A5.
Also, dass der den Headshot gehitted hat, das war eine Mischung aus Glück und ziemlich gut geaimt.
Nicht der, der hier war auch schon gut, aber der nächste ist wirklich gut.
Es gibt Knuschar-Kanals in Battlefield 4, nee, nee, nee, das war Battlefield 3.
Guck mal, den hier jetzt, den Headshot, also das ist wirklich nicht ohne.
Also der war, also das, das ist wirklich Poggers.
Wann kommt wieder ein Dual-Metall? Fuck, wie kommste da drauf jetzt?
Wir haben uns schon seit Jahren nichts mehr aufgenommen.
Also da muss man sagen, also das, das Aiming ist da echt on point von dem Kerl.
Also wenn er hittet, hittet er in den Kopf.
Gut, jetzt trifft er, man kann nicht alles treffen, du kannst ja nicht alles predikten, was die Gegner machen.
Aber trotzdem, also die, die Shots, die er hittet, sind echt krass gewesen am Anfang.
Das war ein Headshot. Hat er irgendwie den Whole-Only-Headshot-Mod oder was ist da los?
Okay, das war mal kein Headshot zur Abwechslung.
Boah, der war auch krass, Alter. Also die Snipes sind wirklich nice, da kannst du nichts daran.
Wollte er jetzt erstmal zu 16 machen?
Boah, das ganze Magazin, ey. Das war nice.
Das war nice, ja, da gäbe ich ihm recht.
Was halt bei diesen Top-Place-Videos immer ist? Locker-Metro zu 80%.
Sind die Gegner AFK? Ja, natürlich. Die Gegner sind total, total, halb Braindead schon in solchen Clips.
Aber du brauchst halt solche Gegner, sonst kriegst du solche Clips nicht gebacken.
Das war ja auch damals, wenn ich irgendwelche Gameplays hochgeladen habe mit gutem Score, da waren halt oftmals ziemlich low-prane Gegner dabei, aber es geht nicht anders.
Du kannst nicht, das Gegenteil ist Modern Warfare Matchmaking. Es macht Spaß für keinen.
Da wird getryhardet gegen getryhardet, geschwitzt gegen geschwitzt und dann gehst du raus halt mit 25 zu 20.
Du brauchst ein bisschen Gegner, die verkacken.
Der Bewegung und die Map-Knowledge setzen sie wirklich zu einem großen Verlust, ein super Clip.
Das war aber auch wieder echt stark und direkt danach auf dem Herd.
Okay, dass er da jetzt nicht tot ist, ist halt wieder hardcore-PP-iger Gegner.
Aber die werden schon heftig zerstört gerade.
Holst du dir das neue Black Ops? Wahrscheinlich schon, aber ich gehe davon aus, wenn da wieder Skill-Based Matchmaking am Start ist, was wahrscheinlich so sein wird,
weil das ist ja eher eine strategische Entscheidung, wahrscheinlich ist das nicht das, was sie sich ausgedacht haben dafür,
sondern irgendwas, wo hier irgendwelche Stonks-Menschen gesagt haben, das ist gut.
Dann weiß ich nicht, wie lange der Multiplayer Bock macht.
Battlefield 6 soll nächstes Jahr kommen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wirklich 100% noch keiner geäußert hat.
Ja, Skill-Based Matchmaking in Warzone ist halt auch total offensichtlich.
Wird Warzone dann geändert zu Cold War? Ich gehe davon aus, dass Warzone quasi weiterhin standalone bleibt, so wie es jetzt auch ist,
dass sie vielleicht ein bisschen weiter noch abkoppeln von Modern Warfare, dass dann auch nicht mehr Modern Warfare drinsteht.
Und dass sie halt Contents aus mehreren Call of Duty reinbringen.
Also die werden garantiert Charaktere aus Black Ops dann in Warzone bringen. Das bringt halt einfach Geld.
Oder es gibt eine neue Map, ja.
Es wird auch mal Zeit, weil ich muss ehrlich sagen, Verdansk ist übelst hässlich.
Also die Warzone-Map ist einfach nur lieblos zusammengekleistert.
Spielst du Warzone? Ich habe relativ viel gespielt, bis vor einem Monat oder so.
Also mal kurzzeitig. Ich habe mal so zwei Monate lang richtig viel gespielt, aber irgendwie habe ich keinen Bock mehr auf das Game.
G18, das Ding ist so ein... Okay, der hätte sich aber umdrehen können. Aber die G18, die haut so rein in dem Spiel.
Genau, Muscle Plays. Also ich fände es halt, was ich halt gut finde, wenn...
Also ohne Skillbase Matchmaking ist halt einfach, du hast halt auch einen Großteil der Runden, da läuft es nicht so gut.
Aber dafür hast du halt mal wieder Runden zwischendurch, wo du halt dann die Noob Lobby schlecht hin erwischt hast.
Wo du halt dann 35-1 alles zerstörst.
Deswegen sind auch die ganzen oder die meisten, sagen wir mal die meisten, ich will es ja nicht allen unterstellen,
die irgendwie ihre Modern Warfare-Luke-Gameplays am Stück raushauen, das ist alles reverse boosted.
Die werden das natürlich nicht zugeben, weil das ja dann automatisch bedeuten würde, sie kriegen es gegen gute Spieler nicht hin.
Was ja auch keine Schande wäre, ehrlich gesagt. Aber die Zuschauer wollen halt gerne sich einbilden, dass das irgendwelche Überspieler sind.
Und wie gesagt, das ist alles reverse boosted.
Oder wenn du dann Videos siehst, Warzone Trios und Quads Solo-Win und solche Geschichten.
Das ist alles, also nicht gefaked, der gewinnt das wirklich.
Das ist entweder Lobby-Klitsch, ich weiß nicht, ob das noch geht auf der PS4, wo du dann quasi Noobs nachjoinen konntest über die Liste.
Oder ob es ein reverse boosted Account ist, keine Ahnung.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht legit im eigentlichen Sinne erspielt.
Gut, dass die Claymore so glänzt.
Weil du siehst das beispielsweise in Warzone, wenn man sich mal...
Irgendwie Huskers oder so anguckt, der, denke ich kann man sagen, einer der besten Spieler in dem Spielmodus ist.
Der geht übelst ab, aber sogar der wird halt...
Sogar der stirbt jede zweite, dritte Runde oder jede dritte Runde und so. Die restliche gewinnt er dann halt einfach.
Stirbt er halt random an irgendwelchem Bullshit, den du nicht vorhersehen kannst.
Sei es irgendein Typ, der hinter irgendeinem Fenster rumcampt oder irgendwas.
Der kriegt halt einfach teilweise richtig krass auf den Sack.
Und weil das halt einfach Sachen sind, die du nicht wirklich vorhersehen, nicht wirklich predikten kannst.
Die halt einfach passieren, wo du auch nicht gegensteuern kannst, großartig.
Du kannst halt irgendwie so safe wie möglich spielen.
So eine Mischung, wie er das macht, aus möglichst vielen Kills, aggressiv, aber die safe Routen wählen.
Aber du kannst immer noch, wenn du die Auswahl hast zwischen, ich laufe jetzt den Weg und den Weg, der Weg ist sicherer, der andere nicht.
Ich kann trotzdem da irgendeiner liegen hinter dem Fenster.
Doch, doch, Cheaters hatten wir auch schon ein paar.
Aber ich muss sagen, es war jetzt, finde ich, nicht so extrem, wie das teilweise dargestellt wurde.
Genau, das stimmt, das habe ich sogar gesehen im Stream, dass da viel Glück dabei ist.
Einfach drauf, wobei man halt sagen muss, er ist halt in Einfach drauf auch ziemlich gut.
Also sowohl wie er teilweise mit seinen Assault Rifles die Gegner über die halbe Map trifft und getrackt kriegt, wenn die mit dem Fallschirm runterspringen und sowas.
Also der hat halt die Mechanics dabei, dass der halt auch quasi nahezu jedes One-on-One und teilweise Two-on-One gewinnt.
Aber trotzdem, es ist viel Glück dabei.
Und endlich heute, der letzte Locker-Klip von Darkfear, diesmal ist er ein bisschen weiter runter, sein Team hat noch eine Flanke zu nehmen und er endet den Job.
Aber hätte er nicht, weil wenigstens den Clip ein bisschen heller machen können, wenn du siehst, gerade den Umriss-LGB vom Gehschner.
Sie ist ja kaum was.
So, ich muss mal kurz gucken, was für eine Bitrate ich eingestellt habe.
Output? Nee. Doch, Output. Ja, 4,9 ist für so normalen Desktop-Gestriebe ganz gut.
Ich bin schon fast eineinhalb Stunden online, bin mir erst geschafft, irgendwie zwei oder drei Videos zu gucken, lul.
So, ich will jetzt mal ein paar Videos machen, die ich jetzt noch nicht verabschieden kann.
Ich will jetzt mal ein bisschen über die Hardware von anderen Leuten lästern.
Ich bin schon fast eineinhalb Stunden online, bin mir erst geschafft, irgendwie zwei oder drei Videos zu gucken, lul.
Ich will jetzt mal ein paar Videos machen, lul.
Bei meiner Ausbildung, die ich damals als Provider gemacht habe, mussten die Azubis einmal morgens den Rundgang im Rechenzentrum machen.
Bei meiner Ausbildung, die ich damals als Provider gemacht habe, mussten die Azubis einmal morgens den Rechenzentrum machen.